how's um raspberries Peter Pan and
welcome to the scariest game ever made
yeah believe me do you
it's ok I don't blame myself and ever
everything the very organized thief and
I know what you're thinking we play this
before
but this is the Halloween version as you
can show clearly tell by the spooks if
you see ghosts like that you know shits
about to get real
yeah in your pants is that oh is that
what the [ __ ] are you to put a tee pitch
please that's that was not a tee all
right
the light of my soul will keep on
glowing in the times of madness the
comic signs like font really puts the
emphasis behind the words
some kind of witch potion or up dammit
I'm making a mess what are you doing get
out but I'm the work up of course that's
where the plan was going alright alright
I have my checklist alright let's see
here um computer towel well so far it
looks like we haven't really found that
much I better go upstairs oh god what
the [ __ ] that's actually spooky what's
with all the letters help me pumpkin
I've done a terrible thing please don't
hurt me god damnit pumpkin it's so
spooky here go check if it's safe
pumpkin ah
hey pumpkin plus it off does it hurt no
close it
nice shot Danny bullet what no no no no
no no pumpkin
come with me pumpkin damn it I dropped
you I'm sorry
fans come back you [ __ ] I'm sorry god
damn it huh maybe I can go back now I
can't I can't
ah but reaper got me what the [ __ ] that
was the scariest game i ever played
god damn huh soul in a jar I need to
find what the hell
dammit gun dad he was supposed to save
me you [ __ ] what happens if I drop you
in this little pot pourri there you go
that's why I'm the boss you just drink
sauce all right let's find all this
stuff radio what the hell he just pooped
out a vase I need it
ah J says what are you doing no stop it
wasn't me I swear to god it was our
Kelly stop following me goddammit what
do you want from me Jesus the family
without faces yes
this was Spence first direction a badass
the lab has a hat on it that's great
Jesus Christ I know my ass is numb shoe
ass but you need to stop staring at it
God this is where you keep bears to
barbecue you're a barbecue right I just
took the barbecue I just sucked it in my
brain I'm like there's the barbecue hog
up I got something my Oh God
I'm just gonna cry you know what I'm
just gonna cry there's the pocket watch
yes oh my god we got so much stuff where
did he go take the lamp
all right lamp you protect me
all right we got this no problem okay I
don't gotta gotta gotta gotta got it I
love go laughs do something god damn it
laughs you son of a [ __ ] laughs you're
blocking me what the hell are you part
of Satan or some [ __ ] I'm not scared of
you
all right so he's not coming here so I'm
just gonna assume that he's dead all
right
I can't jump my I fear that we might
have to go upstairs worried see though
oh god what the [ __ ]
things are father you never bother me I
can love you fine now living in this
olena Vanessa Kayla having a wonderful
time I don't have a lot I need a lot I
feel happy and fine ha ha living in this
whole life loving is a girly life wait a
wonderful time
oh god that's really creepy what are you
doing aah aah aah
that was close Jesus what the fudge cake
don't laugh at me Gunther oh [ __ ] go to
Jos a Bob Bob Jason come out that's it
I'm done thank you thank you
oh god the blockage oh [ __ ] the blockage
aah
Go Go we made it a lab with three
thousand of loot I was a hardcore [ __ ]
man
all right first I gonna have to end it
there hope you boys enjoy watching leave
a like if you did I really appreciate it
and I will see you bros hopefully not in
jail but I know your brothers would bail
me out
right right all right
as always stay awesome rest